У меморіалі біля аеропорту "Схіпгол" під Амстердамом - 298 дерев.
По одному дереву замість кожного з тих, хто так і не повернувся.
Три з них присвячені родині Піта Плуга.
Він втратив свого брата, невістку та їхнього сина на борту рейсу MH17.
Вони залишили двох доньок, двох маленьких доньок на той час.
І я мав сказати їм, що їхній батько, мати та брат померли.
І я також мав сказати про це батькам, які були в той час у лікарні. Це було величезним шоком.
Піт Плуг очолює фонд, який об'єднує тисячі найближчих родичів.
За його словами, катастрофа рейсу MH17 дуже вплинула на все нідерландське суспільство.
Коли тіла репатріювали, вся країна спостерігала за цим по телевізору.
Це було жахливо, але водночас і дуже, дуже зворушливо.
Адже жителі Нідерландів мали стільки співчуття.
Окружний суд Гааги 7 червня цього року розпочав розгляд справи про катастрофу МН17 вже по суті.
У цій справі приблизно 65 тисяч сторінок. А також сотні годин відео- та аудіозаписів.
За словами головуючого судді, це досьє настільки велике, що неможливо обговорити повний зміст.
Суд зосередиться на кількох ключових блоках питань, що стосуватимуться зброї,
якою збили Боїнг, місця запуску ракети та ролі чотирьох підсудних.
Суд обговорюватиме три питання з обвинувального акту. Вони для всіх чотирьох обвинувачених ідентичні.
Перше: чи розбився рейс МН17 внаслідок атаки ракетою "Бук"?
Чи запустили ракету "Бук" з поля поблизу Первомайського?
І третє: чи причетні обвинувачені до цього?
Два роки тому слідча група офіційно назвала чотирьох обвинувачених у причетності до збиття літака рейсу МН17.
Це громадяни Росії: Ігор Гіркін, відомий також як Стрєлков, Сергій Дубинський і Олег Пулатов,
а також громадянин України Леонід Харченко.
За даними нідерландської прокуратури, всі вони відіграли ключову роль у доставці та застосуванні "Бука".
На розгляд справи по суті, як і на попередні судові засідання, ніхто з обвинувачених не прибув.
Лише росіянин Олег Пулатов, який відігравав провідну роль у спецслужбах самопроголошеної "ДНР", представлений адвокатами.
Рейс MH17 вилетів звідси, з аеропорту "Схіпгол", і так і не дістався Малайзії.
Після багаторічних розслідувань суд у Нідерландах ретельно з'ясовує,
що саме сталося у той фатальний день 2014 року, а також хто несе відповідальність.
Наприкінці травня суд провів виїзне засідання на нідерландській військовій авіабазі,
де зібрано ось такий масивний пазл з уламків літака.
За версією нідерландських та бельгійських експертів, ракета"земля-повітря" потрапила у лівий борт літака.
Судді вперше на власні очі побачили реконструкцію збитого Боїнга.
Судова колегія раніше не мала можливості оглянути реконструкцію.
Інші ж учасники процесу раніше вже відвідували це місце.
Тож судова колегія вперше пройшла навколо реконструкції та інших частин уламків, щоб отримати перші враження.
Судова колегія знову хоче підкреслити: ми усвідомлюємо, що це відвідування місця реконструкції MH17
та оглядини реконструкції MH17 в межах офіційного кримінального процесу будуть емоційним навантаженням для родичів.
А це місце катастрофи, що сталася сім років тому.
Усі 298 пасажирів і членів екіпажу загинули під час вибуху літака у небі над зоною бойових дій на сході України.
Докази вказують на зенітно-ракетний комплекс "Бук", який перемістили з Росії на контрольовану проросійськими сепаратистами територію.
Цих чотирьох чоловіків судять заочно. Вони залишаються на волі під фактичним захистом Росії.
Представники родичів загиблих кажуть, що це не робить справу менш важливою.
Правосуддя має перевагу в часі. Може, воно потребуватиме 5, може 10 років, можливо, 50.
Пан Путін та його режим не завжди будуть при владі.
Тож, можливо, якщо відбудеться зміна влади, відбудуться зрушення у політиці, також зміниться політика і в цьому питанні.
Тож у підозрюваних не буде спокою, я впевнений у цьому.
Водночас Піт Плуг каже, що йому все одно, чи потраплять підозрювані за ґрати.
Він просто хоче, щоб з’ясували, що насправді сталося.
Я думаю, що важливо, щоб ми знали, якою була роль Російської Федерації, чи були залучені російські солдати.
Не тільки ті, хто натиснули кнопку, але й ті, на кому в підсумку відповідальність за все, що сталося.
На це можуть піти роки.
Навіть через сім років після катастрофи MH17 він твердо налаштований довести справу до кінця.